Iran has claimed responsibility for an
attack in Northern Iraq that killed at
least four people and wounded six others
missiles and drone attacks were launched
in air Bill near the airport it caused
flights to be suspended although those
these have now resumed Iran's
revolutionary guard says it was
targeting spy centers used by Israel's
intelligence service mosad the prime
minister of the semi-autonomous Kurdish
region has condemned the attack
describing it as cowardly Iran also
targeted isil in Syria in retaliation
for bombings in Iran earlier this month
Al jaer Mahmud abdulwahid has more now
from
Baghdad the security Council of Iraq's
Northern semi-autonomous Kurdish region
has announced that at 11:30 p.m. uh on
uh January 15th the Iran's revolutionary
guard fired ballistic missiles and
targeted civilian areas in the Iraq's
northern city of irbil on on the other
hand Iran's revolutionary guard stated
that in response to uh terrorist crimes
committed by enemies of the Islamic
Republic of Iran the Revolutionary guard
has uh
targeted spage headquarters and uh what
it calls Gathering of anti-iran
terrorist groups and destroyed them now
uh since mid October over uh
120 attacks targeted us and Coalition
forces head cources uh headquarters were
carried out by Iran aligned armed groups
but this is the first time the Iran's
revolutionary guard takes matters into
their own hands the Iran alligned armed
groups in Iraq blame the United States
for as they say standing as a major
supporter of Israel's military campaign
in Gaza and they uh put that uh support
uh to stop as a prerequisite to stop
their attacks against us and Coalition
forces in Iraq well let's bring in Cena
azodi in Washington DC he's an Adjunct
professor at the George Washington
University Cena good to have you with us
so so how significant then are these
Iranian strikes in Northern Iraq and
Syria and what kind of message are the
Iranians sending and who are they
sending it
to um I think they're quite significant
uh they're not that different from
Iran's uh previous uh uh um actions this
is this has been the largest uh missile
strike uh that Iran has conducted since
the assassination of General Suman in
January 2020 um I think uh just reading
from the lines um and the person who was
assassinated Iran Ians are claiming that
this uh the business person this Kurdish
businessman uh um who was uh killed
along with his family was uh connected
to mosad uh now whether this is true or
not that that's a separate issue but um
they also been claiming that this is a
response to the uh killing of uh some
Iranian commanders in addition to uh the
terrorist attacks uh the recent
terrorist attacks in uh k on so I
believe you know the the message is uh
to the Israelis and uh by extension to
the US um CA how much do these attacks
represent a regional escalation of
Israel's war on Gaza given those Iranian
claims that as you say they were
attacking Israeli intelligence Assets in
the
region well I believe they're all
connected to each other um um as long as
the conflict in Gaza continues I think
we will uh see um actions uh but I don't
believe that this is an escalation um um
even uh U just looking at the what the
state department said uh basically
saying that you know they're not
targeting um us uh the spokesperson for
the state department said that this is a
reckless attack but uh again uh he
pointed out that this was not directed
against uh the United States so the US
is kind of playing it down too and
Iranians have repeatedly said that
they're not interested in escalating the
conflict um but again um I think that as
long as the conflict in Gaza continues
we will see um actions like this a t for
Tad here and there seea let's just talk
about isil I mean Iran also claimed that
attacked sites belonging to isil in
Syria um is this being seen then as
retaliation for those isol attacks in
the southwest of Iran earlier this month
that killed 100
people um yes absolutely again we're
seeing a repetition of what Iranians did
in January 2017 when Isis attacked uh
tan uh that year and Iran responded
again with ballistic missiles targeting
U Isis positions or ISO positions in
Syria and we again we're seeing the
similar strategy by Iranians using their
ballistic missiles to send not only a
political message uh uh to the United
States and Regional uh uh countries that
Iran's ballistic missiles is a very
strong force in addition to targeting uh
uh uh uh attack targeting uh threats
excuse me um Cena just a final thought
to you before you go um as you are
saying then is there this fear that
unless there is some kind of ceasefire
uh taking place in Gaza Iran could
continue these sorts of attacks and and
and could that put more pressure then on
the International Community to call for
a ceasefire given the widening the
escalation of the
conflict um um I don't believe that um
um in International Community can do
much as long as the United States with
the influence that it has over Israel
does not pressure the Israelis to uh go
for a ceasefire we did see that during
the six St ceasefire that we had a few
uh a month ago or so where the hostages
were exchanged the attacks this the
similar attacks that we've seen from the
houthis or other uh uh groups they also
stopped but once the conflict resumed
we're seeing again more attacks more
attacks and the problem is I think my
main concern is at one of these attacks
uh there could be casualties us
casualties which would force the United
States to respond and then it could
escalate without anyone actually wanting
War all righta you're really good to get
your thoughts and your analysis thank
you very much indeed Cena for talking to
us thank you